and rookie max kranik just three starts
573 era first time facing these brewers
first time pitching here at pnc park
ready to play ball here first ball
swinging and colton wong delivers one to
center field
and away we go the brewers swung the
bats well last night
and the brewers won the first game and
now another hit
really adamus goes to the opposite field
back-to-back singles and the brewers in
business early tonight in pittsburgh
there it is bullet yeah there it is
whoa
[Applause]
he's out of the baseline but
can you imagine if he had gone back to
first i mean add that to the list yeah
but he was out of the baseline here's
avi garcia two for four the run scoring
double last night
that ball is scalded into center field a
base hit in the score is cold wong and
the brewers with three hard-hit balls
they strike first tonight as garcia
drives in number 60 on the air adrian
hauser gets the ball start number 18.
he's won three in a row he won his last
timeout against the white sox that was
an american family field henry lee
picked up freddie peralta
and that one hangs up a little bit
nagowski
sends one to taylor and that will retire
the side
that is a fair ball narvaez
allows it to roll into fair territory
makes the play to retire
the pirates pitcher i mean a lot of
those already off the bat to the pirates
a couple of comebackers and now a little
squiver in front of the plate
three and two and he got him
that one had a lot of movement away from
the left-handed batter
camel strikes out for hauser that's his
first k
and the pitch swinging a hard ground
ball kicks off of hauser towards second
base wong has it and he'll hold on to it
hayes will have his second hit tonight
nobody's looking at anything
i don't know
yeah
got a hold of that one
but it's gonna hang up headed to the
wrong part of the park in pittsburgh and
kane puts it away
2-2 pitch from krannic
and narvaez a ground ball hugging the
line it's going to get
down into the right field corner big
turn for omar he's going to dig for two
and he's going to be in there sliding
with a lead-off double narvaez who had
the two hit night last night with the
home run
doubles down the first baseline here
just hugging that first baseline not hit
overly hard
but out of the range of nagowski
and narvaez is it second now for avisail
garcia
oh and to the count
oh man hits that like a bullet
that's all crannic right there narvaez
had to freeze on the line drive he'll
end up at third and you just gotta
wonder about that pitch right i mean
what is he thinking i mean he
just swinging a pitch way off the
outside corner breaking ball then he
gives him a fastball actually slider
this one hangs
two men are out still runners at the
corners
and here is lorenzo kane
1-1 pitch
and here's the line drive into right
center field that's going to plug the
gap and roll all the way to the wall for
lorenzo kane one run is in garcia's
around third he's gonna score it's a two
run double for lorenzo kane
and the brewers lead it three to nothing
[Applause]
that was some solid contact for lorenzo
cain a drive into right center field
yes the wall three runs scoring for the
brewers come with two outs
and pits right on the outside corner
runs and goes right with it wasn't
exactly the flare you're looking for but
it's a bullet off the wall
not too far away no not bad
the 1-0 swing line drive towards right
it's down a base hit for rowdy teles
stay hot
another base hit for rowdy
14 scoreless innings in this series
taylor banks one through for a base head
found a hole his first hit of the game
first and second nobody out
and the pitch from krannic inside and it
hit him ooh he went down in a hurry
[Applause]
ouch
and lorenzo walking around a little bit
he is
making his way out towards first base
lorenzo was not pleased
that fastball the road
up and in on him hit him right in the
middle of the back
and craig council is
coming out to check on lorenzo
well the brewers have them loaded now
with nobody out chance to deliver a
knockout punch here in this sixth inning
perhaps big spot in the six for
milwaukee
and maria's down the line fair
into the corner it goes
to les is in here comes taylor he'll
score scampering back to third is kane
it's a two rbi double
for luisa reyes and the brewers lead
five nothing there we go luis able to
break it open
a bases loaded double right down that
left field line and
there it is a slider
a 3-1 pitch he's it he hangs it and is
able to rip it down the line last 10
appearances the brewers have scored at
least five runs for adrian hauser 3-1
pitch to colton wong
swing a line drive right center field
moving over polanco going back to tag is
kane he will come in and score on a
sacrifice fly
from colton wong
with the bases loaded one out in the
sixth inning trying to shake nagowski
here the one-two pitch and a cold strike
three
generous call and nagowski
was upset last time when he was run up
and now a much milder
pirates are oh for seven with runners in
scoring position
in this series and lower trying to keep
it that way two and one to count on the
pirate catcher
popped him up
it's gonna get him out of the inning
wong is in the grass he's got it for the
out and the pirate strand the base is
loaded
here is tyrone taylor
[Music]
there's a shot through for a base hit
tyrone taylor
around third headed home as garcia throw
his cut off snap throw to first taylor's
back
it's an rbi single the brewers add to
their lead seven nothing milwaukee and
again rock another delivery with a
runner in scoring position he uh does
struggle well maybe give him some more
time he's only 22.
he belts one out toward the notch indeed
he's got a ton of power and rodolfo
castro hits home run number four into
the deepest part of the bullpen
that was a massive blast for castro
the future is now
and how
castro clears the deck with a cannonball
he homers off hater
castro now has five big league hits and
five home runs
how do you do
rudy
[Applause]
broken bat fly ball left field taylor's
got it and the ball game is over the
brewers win another series
they take the first two against the
pittsburgh pirates on the road